i hated her so
much it it the it flame flames
flames on the side of my face
breathing breath heaving breath i know
it's an ability of mine i can talk
without saying anything
what do you mean murder well the board
game is mostly made out of flat things
we try to fill them out of course
there's somebody that's guaranteed
and that is the mystery who done it
it's a whodunit you know and that's part
of the fascination so i look guilty
i didn't do it somebody help me please
mr green
mr green is a very special man he is an
acting colonel
in the united states army he's a
professor she's bright
aggressive assertive she's the senator's
wife
it'd be so obvious if the butler did it
don't you think what's this place for
you
indeed no sir i'm merely a humble butler
what exactly do you do
i battle sir it's a chance to create a
new stereotype
from the ashes of an old
and besides it's all that english actors
ever get to play in america
sorry didn't mean to frighten you you're
a bit late for that
i think the the burden of proof is on
the viewer
and uh that's what makes this film a
little bit different i have no idea who
did it
maybe i shouldn't have said that but
someone did do it i don't know
interesting
we're not on camera are we we had to
sign a contract with paramount saying
that we wouldn't reveal anything
and that's the fun of it you know
i had to stop her from screaming you're
not going to know this
i don't know if i want to get into that
you're not you're not going to know
well you will definitely find out did i
do what
the murder well there's more than one
i find i like everybody and it worries
me
[Laughter]
just checking everything all right yep
two corpses everything's fine
adding a twist to the twist is the fact
that the movie has three different
endings
so determining just who done it is even
more complicated than it seems
it was very hard for me to you know make
heads or tales of the script it was very
complicated
it's a free country don't you know that
i didn't know it was that free
it was difficult as an actor if you knew
that in one theater for instance if you
knew that you were the murderer then you
would have to play the whole role a
little bit as if you were guilty
so it was a little difficult trying to
find out how to tread that line yeah
in fact none of us really knew in fact
until this evening
who who was the killer i'm very sad to
say that i think i off somebody in this
version
wait a minute so who did i kill
my butler oh shuts
the point is that's the game the game is
intricate in that
there are several possibilities and in
this film also up to at a certain point
there are
three or four possible things that could
happen i mean you don't really know the
truth all right we've done it
they all did it